it would be easy to write a title based
on yesterday's open AI leak that
language model progress is hitting a w
and it would be just as easy to write an
all caps hype headline if I only listen
to the very latest cherry-picked quotes
from say sam Orman CEO of open AI but I
want to try to convey the Nuance behind
the headlines and we'll be diving into
some brand new papers to do so the
ground truth lies somewhere between both
extremes and even open AI don't know
exactly where here's how the video would
look if I only wanted to focus on the
bare case for llms or AI more generally
and undisclosed Source at openai leaked
information apparently to the
information the article was published
late yesterday and here it is while the
number of people using chat PT has
soared the rate of Improvement it says
for the basic building blocks the
language models underpinning them
appears to be slowing down the article
isn't talking about a particular product
or a way of generating outputs from a
model it's talking about the underlying
model the current core model of open AI
is GPT 40 and so the next model would
naturally be called say GPT 5 the
suggestion from this article is that the
more favored name is Orion but still
we're talking about that core underlying
pre-trained model at least at an early
stage that new Orion model was looking
pretty decent remember this comes from a
person who heard comments directly from
Sam wman at open aai so presumably an
open aai staff member and that person
said though open aai had only completed
20% of the training process for this new
model Orion it was already on par with
Gypsy 4 in terms of intelligence and
abilities to fulfill tasks and answer
questions that sounds decent right but
when the training was finished according
to this person the final increase in
quality was Far smaller compared with a
jump between gpt3 and gp4 so it's
apparently better than Prime models its
performance exceeds those Prime models
but not by as much as previous leaps and
the article gives a bit more detail here
some researchers at the company believe
Orion isn't reliably better than its
predecessor in handling certain tasks
like coding it might be better at
language tasks but remember the tradeoff
for a bigger model is that it would
generally be slower and more expensive
and why according to the article might
progress have slowed down well roughly
speaking you can think of gp4 as having
trained on most of the accessible web
they kind of ignored copyright to
basically train on anything they could
grab hold of at that point it becomes
quite hard to scale up another 10 times
another order of magnitude because where
are you going to get that extra data you
can tell though that the article is
somewhat guessing because they also put
forward the hypothesis that it could be
that it's just getting too expensive to
train models they selectively quote gome
Brown who said that it's soon going to
cost hundreds of billions of dollars to
train the Next Generation and at some
point the scaling Paradigm breaks down
how do I know that's a selective quote
well because gome Brown just today said
so saying he was selectively quoted and
that he thinks that there won't be a
Slowdown in AI progress anytime soon the
theme though of the article is clear and
they quote one open AI investor saying
this we're increasing the number of gpus
used to train AI but we're not getting
the intelligence improvements out of it
at all and another analyst was quoted at
the end saying You could argue that for
now we are seeing a plateau in the
performance of llms as the author of
simple bench I could bring in tons of
examples of the latest models making
silly mistakes that a human might not
make then throw in a few more quotes
making samman or open AI look bad and
call it a day alternatively I could make
a video focused only on the most hype
worthy of clips for example here's four
times in the last few days samman has
given us quotes that make it seem like
we're on the verge of a giant leap
forward first he says we know what to do
to reach AGI this is the first time ever
where I felt like
we actually know what to do like I think
from here to
building an AGI will still take a huge
amount of work there are some known
unknowns but I think we basically know
what to go what to go do and it'll take
a while it'll be hard but that's
tremendously exciting second and by the
way these are in approximately ascending
order of optimism he says scal is going
to continue yes for a long time is the
trajectory of model capability
Improvement going to keep going like it
has been going and the answer that I
believe is yes for a long time have you
ever doubted that totally then he
mysteriously alludes to a quote
breathtaking research result that he
can't talk about what was one thing that
surprised you in the last month Sam it's
a research result I can't talk about but
it is breathtakingly
good fourth and this has to be the most
extreme example he hinted at solving all
of physics using AI you know we you
mentioned earlier that thing about cover
all of physics I uh I was wanted to be a
physicist wasn't smart enough to be a
good one had to like contribute in this
other way but the fact that somebody
else I really believe is now going to go
solve all the physics with this stuff
like I'm so excited to be alive for that
let's get to level four so happy for
whoever that person is yeah to his
credit at least he could see the
grandiosity in some of his claims the
typed female Twitter account jokingly
quoted samman we are a few thousand days
away from building God we will build
Sons on Earth unify physics and
Resurrect The worthy Dead interview host
sounds like this will be really
impactful for startups Sam wman
definitely so hopefully you can see that
just by selecting which news stories to
quote and which Clips to use you can
present entirely different stories what
then is the truth and how will we know
well a quick hint before I give some
evidence to that effect is that even
open AI don't know that's according to a
key researcher who I'll quote in a
moment this paper Frontier math isn't
just interesting because it gives the
results of whether current AI models can
compete at the very Frontier of
mathematics answer no they can't but
it's also interesting because it shows
us what needs to happen before they can
they came up with around a 100 questions
developed in collaboration with 60
mathematicians from leading institutions
professors International math Olympiad
question writers and field medalists
think of that like the Nobel Prize for
mathematics they go on that these
problems typically demand hours or even
days for specialist mathematicians to
solve and Terren to widely regarded as
one of the smartest human beings alive
said these are extremely challenging
even he couldn't solve most of them yeah
so I took a look at the the 10 problems
uh you sent I think of the I could do
the anal number three ones in principle
and the others I don't know how to do
but I know who to ask how about the
latest language models well they can
solve between 1 and 2% of them that
though isn't too disgraceful given that
these are unpublished problems novel
ones not found in the training data this
Benchmark though should serve as
somewhat of a canary in the coal mine
because before any model can quote solve
all of physics you'd have thought it
could get at least 50 to 90% in this
Benchmark why not 100% because they
estimate an error rate in The Benchmark
itself of around1 % quick sidebar is
that other benchmarks are known to have
an error rate around 10% for example the
MML U so depending on your perspective
this could either be a sobering wakeup
call about the remaining deficiencies of
models or actually startlingly
impressive is it the long context window
of Gemini 1.5 Pro that enables it to get
2% or is 01 preview being underestimated
when it says it gets 1% on page N9 of
the paper they admit that those results
were from a single evaluation and when
they tested models across repeated
trials 01 preview demonstrated the
strongest performance of course you
probably don't need reminding that this
is just 01 preview the full 01 comes out
maybe in the next 2 weeks if I was only
trying to present the pessimistic case
however I could focus on this quote one
mathematician interviewed about the
difficulty of the frontier math problems
said this Benchmark problems aren't
quite the same as coming up with
original proofs so much of mathematics
takes years to develop and research and
that's really hard to encapsulate in a
benchmark on the other hand if you
wanted to get hyped you could hear this
quote from the co-founder of anthropic
you're saying these things are dumb
people are making the math test
equivalent of a basketball eval designed
by NBA All Stars because the things have
gotten so good at basketball that no
other tests stand up for more than 6
months before they're obliterated by AI
models should of course be interesting
to see if my my own Benchmark simple
bench is obliterated in the next 6
months we tested the new small Claude
3.5 ha cou from anthropic and it
displaced GPT 40 mini to reach 13th at
15.6% in simple bench simple bench is
all about testing common reasoning and
the human Baseline is in the mid 80s
while Frontier models get around the low
40s at this point I would definitely
forgive you for being torn between
optimism and pessimism but where do I
come down well the key to further
progress could come from a different
axis entirely data efficiency after all
to solve Frontier math problems you
either need to be a genius or you need
to have access to relevant training data
that is almost non-existent there are
apparently only a dozen papers with the
relevant things said Terren to now of
course maths isn't everything and many
of you will rightly argue that general
intelligence AGI might arrive well
before a model can Crush Frontier math
but still the challenges of solving
Frontier math are roughly analogous to
solving other domains so I would ask
Will companies like openai get access to
those few dozen papers that contain the
relevant reasoning steps and even if
they do can the models themselves pick
out the signal from the noise pick out
those reasoning steps contained within
those dozens of papers from the tens of
trillions of words that they're also
trained on the 01 family of models from
openai suggests that is at least
possible if you're new to the channel
and you have no idea what I'm talking
about when I talk about the 01 family of
models do check out my video on the
topic the very brief tldr is that that
test time compute Paradigm suggests that
models might be able to extract at
inference time when they're doing
outputs just one output among tens of
thousands that contains the necessary
reasoning steps if that's correct expect
rapid progress on the frontier math
benchmark of course those reasoning
steps do have to be found somewhere in
the training data that the weights of a
model derive from but as long as they
are progress can continue and at this
point I'll bring us back to the article
that kicked everything off even if open
AI can only improve the quality of the
underly model the gbt 5 or Orion at a
slower rate it will result in a much
better reasoning output in short because
if we're asking a model to Output 10,000
different answers there's a greater
chance that at least one of those
answers is correct and again if the
quality of the underlying model is even
just incrementally better it has a
significantly better chance of
discerning that correct answer from the
noise hopefully I've conveyed that the
ground truth reality is a lot more
nuanced and complex than the positive
panglossian perspective or the
everything's hit a wall perspective here
at last then is the quote that I've been
teasing for quite a while one of the
Stars Behind the training of the 01
family of models said he can see
progress continuing at least for one or
two more years but they simply don't
know how long that will last I think
it's still
unclear um I think that basically a lot
of the assumptions about why we would be
hitting a wall need to be reevaluated
completely given that this there's this
new paradigm and so we're still trying
to figure that out um I suspect that a
lot of other people are going to be
trying to figure that out and the answer
is like right now we don't know um
looking at the limitations of
pre-training and saying that's going to
be a Blocker on continued progress I
think that that is no longer a blocker
if even open AI don't know how much
further scaling can go how can we know
I'm going to end though on a lighter
note because not everything in AI is
about text based benchmarks and
reasoning according to the well-known
co-founder and CEO of Runway open aai is
planning to finally release Sora in
around 2 weeks Sora is of course that
Incredible video video generation model
first described back in February so even
if you're one of those unlike me who
believes that reasoning progress will
ground to a whole that doesn't mean
progress in other modalities will too
what would explain the discrepancy well
we just have so much more data from
videos say YouTube and from images to
train models on in those domains than we
do for text indeed any domain where
there's an abundance of data expect
progress to continue rapidly take for
example speech DET text and you guys
have heard before on the channel talking
about Channel sponsor assembly Ai and
their universal one model well even in a
surprise to me they have now come out
with universal 2 I'll link the research
page below because there is an absolute
ton I could go through probably goes
without saying that the word error rates
are much lower for Universal 2 compared
to all these other models that's why as
I've mentioned many times before I
actually reached out to assembly AI to
be a channel sponsor and speaking of
audio don't forget to check out my
podcasts and exclusive videos on my
patreon which is called AI insiders what
am I up to now almost 40 videos and
podcasts if you leave this video neither
overly hyped nor overly skeptical I've
done my job and I get that that leaves
us in somewhat of a weird place so here
is an AI generated video that captures
just a bit of that weirdness can a robot
write a symphony can a robot turn a
canvas into a beautiful
masterpiece can you
[Music]
well done to DAR 3D who put that video
together and a big thank you to all of
you for watching to the end thank you so
much and have a wonderful day